ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show uh great to be here fun show
last night in San Antonio we had to come
back here to California uh to do a
podcast and we're leaving immediately to
Dallas um uh with the good people of
Titan Aviation uh who have been helping
us out and I appreciate that I have been
flying private uh recently and I am sort
of developing a problem I I don't and
here's the thing and I know this is
seems you know many of you have not had
the experience of flying in a private
plane and that's not my
fault to be honest it's not my fault
it's not you know what I mean you have
things I don't have okay families all
that good stuff right they're always
nice right they always work out but I'm
a proponent of family I am even in the
instance when uh you know your kids are
running around Arizona killing others I
still think I still think a family is
good even when you're doing drugs
together M but I've been flying private
uh my jet broker Dirk takes care of us
um but you know I'm learning lessons
about PT you cannot engage these people
in conversation they will never ever
stop Pilots will never first of all a
friend of mine brought up a good point
they are the truck drivers of the sky no
one cares about what P when they talk
when you're sitting in the plane and
they go to speak you roll your eyes you
can barely hear them they try to make
like a joke you go the only time you
ever want to hear from a pilot is when
things are getting funky when there's
turbulence when there's weather and they
come on to go hey folks we this will be
about another five minutes everything's
fine that's the only thing you ever want
to hear from a pilot or if you've been
sitting in a commercial flight and
you're on the tarmac and you're ready to
go and they go hey guys just a couple of
routine safety checks we're all clear
we're uh we're getting out of here you
know the hold at Logan has been lifted
we're we're on our way to Boston that's
the only time you want to hear but in
the private thing they're right there so
occasionally you make the
mistake of engaging them and I mean
number one they get out of the
seat one of them gets out of the seat
and comes back and starts asking you
what it's like to be a
comedian one of them last night I swear
one of them is out of the seat for a
half hour just talking to us the other
one could have been dead could have had
a stroke and no one would have known
he's in the back of the plane he's a
nice
guy and he's chatting and then he like
tells I'm not trying to I'm not ratting
I'll never say who this is by the way um
but then he goes hey because you guys
like Aviation so much which I I don't
even know that I do I don't know that I
do I asked a few questions about it I
guess most people and this is why rich
people become pieces of [__] by the way
this is how it happens because you have
enough of these experiences and then you
just start giving people the cold
shoulder or or saying hey hey hey man
yeah I I don't I don't care but I'm
trying to Fain enthusiasm for well what
is the what is the visual approach what
how does that work and I do think it's
cool I think flying's cool so I ask a
few questions I mean 25 minutes and then
he goes do be then he he goes up there
he comes back again and goes because you
like Aviation so much does anyone want
to go up
[Laughter]
front I'm like what so I'm with a couple
of my idiot friends who are tinier or
smaller than me I'm like I'm not going
up front I don't want to go up front I
don't like Aviation that much I don't
want to go up front I don't want my
friends are up there taking photos one
of my friends hops in the seat and he's
sitting in the seat of the jet which is
by the way they encourage this these
pilots in my idiot friend is in the
seat and then they're like do you want
to sit in the seat I go I can't fit in
the seat and I'm not going to be killed
by my own fat 38,000 feet in the
sky like my fat hits a button and we're
dead now
and they have I they have to explain
that how mortifying that is well he died
because he was fat was it a heart attack
no he was taking a private plane from
San Antonio late at night he got in the
he got in the co-pilot seat in the
cockpit his gut touched a button and
shut the Hydraulics off and now we're
all
dead I mean what I was insane as that
can you imagine the humiliation
of that type of death we're in a death
spiral cuz I shut the engines
off with my
ass I'm telling you it's was
crazy but now I've learned now I just
you don't you can't speak to them if
they say anything I'm GNA learn a few
lines of another language to just say
you know what I mean like a little
Norwegian to just you
know I mean it was it was it was it was
wild we like we love our people that
always hook us up and treat us well but
it's like do you want to come up front
I'm like what what that's not allowed
that can't be allowed that's Pro there's
no way that's allowed maybe it is
allowed but I do love a private flight I
do I love the little FBO which is the
little private airport there's something
nice about it jet people there's
something nice about the people that
take Jets to a Jackson Hole uh we met
that lovely older woman who was taking a
jet going to Jackson Hole to see a a
hockey tournament or a hockey tournament
in Jackson Hole and she was just taking
a jet you know just a lovely old woman
lovely old kind of you know fun Trump
mom you know getting on that plane
everyone is talking about the Border
this is all I hear about now in the news
is the border and all I can say is well
first of all my initial thought is don't
go this is my initial thought like who
are these people going to the Border all
the time like why are you going like
I've never even been I gotta be honest
with you I don't even know where it is
like I don't even know where it is I
know that Doug Stan hope lives near it
and the closest I've ever got was Doug
Stan Hope's house I have never gone to
the Border I don't know where it
is what's the big deal but now I've read
about it there actually people that live
there there are like towns on the border
MH of Mexico and the United States of
America there are Caravans of migrants
large groups of people coming through
the Mexican border some of them coming
from South America Central
America and there's instability in some
regions there specifically Ecuador right
they're popping off in Ecuador so
there's only going to be
more if you want to call them
refugees I don't know if they are
refugees but some of them are some of it
is economic migration where people are
coming to make a living to make
money um but we don't have a border
really now we have this area where
people
are coming and there's nothing to be
done so now the federal government which
is our President Joe
Biden uh and is in a war he's locked in
a war with the state government of
Texas and I got to say I probably
support Texas here I don't know
what I don't know what the war is I
imagine the war is the Biden
Administration uh is is is is
tying Texas's hands they're they're not
able
to enforce the
law and because they're saying federal
law supersedes state law and they're
saying
that cuz Texas if you remember is is
sending out um people on Horseback with
whips to kind of wrangle you know which
by by the way is their culture that is
what they do that is what they do this
isn't like you know what I mean like
that is what they do like I know we
think the culture of Texas is supposed
to be like Apple's AI division moving to
Austin look at we got a green juice no
they're they're they rope Mexicans down
there with a horse and a [__] whip
that's what they do that's why they're a
state they're not a state because Elon
Musk moved Tesla to Texas they're not a
state because my good friend Joe Rogan
has a comedy club there they are a state
because when when when things get going
they send out people on Horseback to
whip the Mexican and some of them are
Mexican some there are more Latinos in
Texas than there are whites
there's a lot of Latino cow Mexican
Cowboys
wrangling other types of Latinos
Mexicans and Central Americans and it
that is not my business nor should it be
yours it seems like it's it's a it's a
cultural thing that isn't you know it
looks it looks on the outside it doesn't
look great the Optics are bad because no
one resp respects the Western way of
life anymore you understand like no one
respects the you know what I mean the
shoe leather kind of just you know like
getting the boots on getting on the
horse people don't rope and ride the way
they used to people don't but these are
people that are enforcing the law in the
way it has been enforced
forever whipping and
wrangling and this is what's going on in
Texas you have people out
there because the people are coming in
illegally and they are breaking a law
listen whether you like it or not that's
what's happening and then the sheriff's
in Texas or the border patrol I don't
know who these people are I don't know
who it is Walker Texas Ranger I don't
know but they're they're Rangers these
are real live Texas law enforcement and
they're on
Horseback and they're and they're doing
what they do MH and it looks
terrible to people that are living like
people in New York City they read the
New York Times They open it they I so my
do you see what they're doing in
Texas they're whipping the Mexicans in
Texas that are coming over the Border
but this is just the way that they they
number one they operate on Horseback
they
do now the thing that they're using that
um what is it it's a what is it what are
they doing there with that it's a whip
isn't it but is it isn't it doesn't it
serve another purpose as
well I
heard this is what they're saying right
now get some of these photos up because
it doesn't look great I think they're
lassoing the migrant I don't think
they're whipping them they're doing a
lasso which which is not easy that is a
difficult thing to do they're on
Horseback now remember the migrants are
not just waiting to be lassoed they're
running they're running around and you
are on
Horseback with the lasso and it's got to
be big because M much like a cartoon you
are lassoing lots of people it's not
just one person occasionally you lass of
one person you or there's maybe a little
baby goes your little [__] get them
you know get a little toddler runs away
from the group you go boom and that's
easier but if you're going to do a big
lasso you know it's like um it's not
easy it's not easy it's difficult
and this is their
culture what is this the Rio Grand the
people are coming out of the Rio Grand
uh yes these and these are they were
using the Reigns The Reigns of the horse
yes as they were they're let loosening
them out and then I guess and then
whipping the migrant that's what it
looked like yeah but they're saying that
they weren't whipping the mark but
listen how else and I'm not saying that
we should whip
people
but there's got to be some enforcement
of the
border and it is
Texas you get what I mean
yeah I don't know what they can do
they're on a horse they could pull out a
gun and shoot the people no one would
like that no one's going to be happy
with that YouTube's not even happy I
just said it I guarantee you they're not
even happy with that these freaks in
Venice aren't even happy with that that
I said it but I'm not but what would
they do they're on a horse what are they
going to do if the people are coming
now there's people that go you you must
welcome like the Humane thing to do and
there's an argument about to do it's a
Humane thing to do with say come welcome
here you are you this is your new
home now the problem with that is that
they don't have the resources to do that
all of these states they don't and the
federal government has made a mess of
providing resources for these people
when they come here in New York City
they're sitting on the street the mayor
of New York's like we we don't have the
room the space the money we don't have
the
resources so I know everybody wants to
say that like these yeah dozens of
migrants are sleeping at Logan Airport
in
Boston there there isn't there aren't
resources to deal with this crisis right
now and
obviously these are human beings this is
you know this is a this is a human
tragedy they're not like political
pawns we obviously are funny about the
whole situation that's what we do but
they are human being
but that being
said there has to be
some
process by which people come into this
country this is the reason Trump won his
first election this is the reason he
might win his second election because
everybody knows that if you're rich
you're not affected by any you're not
affected by anything you're not affected
by anything Rich PE I've only been Rich
for a few years I was broke my entire
life my family was lower middle class
they SC they they scratched and clawed
to get things my mother died in a public
hospital and my father my father has a
it's fine the home frankly it's fine
it's nothing to be they have a water
view I like it it's not terrible uh it's
fine it's fine now and I it's fine now
so what I'm saying is that when you are
rich what I've have noticed as someone
who's had has a little bit of money is
we're I'm really not affect like I'm not
affected by this I don't have kids in
school I don't have to deal with like my
my
kid uh broke his leg playing soccer and
now we're not and ER that's crowded it's
crazy and there's I'm not affected by
this okay I'm not losing out on work it
actually only helps me as it does many
rich people that can just you know get
they get low wage labor they uh are able
to hire landscapers people come do their
nails people can come and uh do work on
their home uh they can have homes built
very quickly and cheaply by by people
that are not being paid American wages
to do it so the benefits to the rich of
immigration are a
ton it is actually the middle class and
the lower class that bear the brunt of
the negative impacts of
immigration those are the people who are
more likely to deal with some of the
negative they have increased competition
for work uh the state and local
resources are being drained by just too
many
people um they are dealing with uh you
know crowded hospitals crowded Schools
they're potentially dealing with a an
uptick in crime not to say that all the
immigrants are criminals but there are
people that come to this country they
don't have skills and some of those
people inevitably are going to have to
make money have to make some type of
living um illegally like many of our own
citizens make a living
illegally so
you know it's it's just a situation
where this is the biggest issue by the
way we we covered on the patreon the
Oregon drug stuff which is also funny
too that's also one of the biggest I
believe the biggest issue issue of the
next 50 years on planet Earth besides
climate change and by the way every
prediction I've ever made I've been
correct let's be honest the biggest
issue is going to be the mass migration
of people from one area to another that
could be due to political instability
economic conditions climate change this
is the all the political upheaval in
Europe and America is all directly
related to this singular issue that
countries cannot take an unending
stream of immigrants without some type
of
backlash from the citizens that live in
those countries this is a fact people
tend to like their countries they tend
to like the way things are that doesn't
make them racist doesn't make them Nazis
they just like familiarity they like
tradition they like things the way they
are so the United States has already
taken in over 100 million immigrants in
the last you know 100 years there's no
other country that's absorbed more
people from more different cultures than
the United States of America but we have
a lot of problems everyone knows it
we've got wealth inequality okay we've
got a small you know a concentration of
wealth in smaller and smaller hands we
have uh Automation and AI disrupting
work we have uh a tremendous amount of
debt uh from from Full hearty Wars we
shouldn't have fought um we're
maintaining a very expensive Empire all
around the world you know at at a
certain point you have to wonder about
the amount of people that you can just
bring in this is just a fact this is not
I love
different cultures I come from New York
City I don't care I don't want to live
uh in a white ethn state it has no
appeal to me I don't care you know I
think though that you have to do it in a
way that makes people you know
like
understand the cost benefit analysis of
of of what's Happening you have you know
people need to understand the cost
benefit of it they have to go yes there
are some potential negatives here are
the positives that's why it shouldn't be
an emotional issue it should just be an
issue where it's like you know boomers
are going to retire this is real the
boomers are going to retire now they
don't want to they don't want to and we
have some articles we'll talk about
later in the show where the Boomers
actually don't want the world to
continue a friend of mine sent me this
border thing this is so hilarious over
in Instagram and was basically like what
a and the she sent me this article like
are we going to have a civil war and she
goes what an exciting time to be
alive they are giddy at the prospect of
the entire American experiment failing
and the uh civilization going dark
boomers are bullant at the they are
sitting around pubs and Casual
restaurants and they're sitting at
country clubs and they are actually very
excited about the prospect of
civilization crumbling because they are
at the end of their life the Boomers
never wanted their children to have
better lives than they did ever the
Boomers were threatened by their
children the Boomers viewed their
children as obstacles to their own
success and
fulfillment this is all in the book
coming out I know you don't think it's
coming out I don't care what you think
it's coming out it'll be there in the
summer you read it on a beach but this
is all true and the more I observe these
Boomer which I have for my entire life
and I'm really keying in on it
now what I'm noticing is that they're
kind of a death cult the boomers are a
death cult in the way that radical Islam
is a death
cult radical Islam doesn't really have
an interest in anybody existing that
isn't a a devotee of the of what they
think and what they believe Boomers did
the exact same way they are ready to
usher in the apocalypse and they're
doing it gleefully they're holding on
all the houses and all the money you
know we have an article here
80% of the stock market
80% of the stock market is owned by
elderly people
Boomers they can sell it and trigger a
downturn here we go your grandma
is a downside risk to the stock market
how more old people owning equities
could exacerbate a downt the boomers are
holding the American economy
hostage they're holding it hostage and
they can at any
time flood the market by selling all
their stock taking all the
cash now many people go well they're
going to take it from medical
emergencies and they're going to they're
going to take the cash
and whatever they're going to do with it
okay they're going to like fund some
nightmarish thing it's like pinky in the
brain with these people like they're
going to take the cash out of the stock
market so they can build a laser to zap
the world the way that they are going on
now refusing to sell these mcmansions
they will not downsize they will not
give up their jobs Biden will not step
aside he's 80 80 he's an octogenarian
he's elderly he doesn't he's he's
foaming at the mouth he's got dementia
and and he will not step aside who that
[__] that just died in office was it
Feinstein they die in office now these
senators and Cong one article I read one
of the Pentagon by the way prepare to
report this is good true the Pentagon is
prepared to report now one of the
threats they talk about bio weapons
they're talking about covid uh it's on
drudge this is a new thing they wrote
about how like you know here's the
threat uh threats that we
anticipate okay here are the threats
that we anticipate coming one of the
threats okay is this is great A new
study by the office of the Secretary of
Defense provides a unique window into
the views of military planners and how
they see future forms of
warfare so now we know covid we go da d
d da we got Co so here if you go up so I
love this
okay
additionally listen to this okay
Additionally the author's caution
against the possibility of government
employees replacing their natural ey
lenses with artificial ones containing
tiny cameras connected to micro storage
devices the small cameras could collect
classified intelligence and leak it to
foreign adversaries okay now the reason
that they're worried about this by the
way come up go up a little a little bit
here they're talking about in another
intriguing scenario seemingly inspired
by the decline of Senator Diane
Feinstein and this time set in a more
distant future the report suggests that
elderly Congressional leaders desperate
to retain power this is everything I've
ever said it's in the this report that
the Pentagon has now just come out the
Pentagon is saying the biggest threat
to the body politic to the survival of
our country is not climate change it's
not for all its other issues immigration
it is Boomers Boomers will
not relinquish power listen to this is
actually really fascinating in another
intriguing scenario seemingly inspired
by the decline of Senator Diane
Feinstein and this time set in a more
distant future and by the way they mean
like 5 years from now the report
suggests that elderly Congressional
leaders desperate to retain power
secretly install state-of-the-art brain
computer interface
devices these devices commonly used
among wealthy senior citizens in the
scenario initially helped the Senators
regain mobility and speech after years
of clear cognitive decline this by the
way is the wildest report I have read in
a long time I read these things so you
don't have to I sift through them I work
hard to take these private planes you
don't think I do many of you don't think
I do but I'm all the time reading these
things and it's not just something I've
read six seconds before I talk about it
I peruse I go over and over and over and
over all these things I travel the world
talking to people I do interviews with
people migrants terrorists Gilbert goons
I'm all over the world I'm over the
world I'm not walking around Beverly
Hills looking houses I can't afford I'm
in Yemen I'm in Yemen with the yen
and I say look at you you starving Yemen
and I give them a little uh you know
little
biscuit these devices commonly used
among wealthy senior citizens in this
scenario helped the Senators regain
mobility and speech after years of clear
cognitive decline however when the brain
implants malfunction causing erratic and
belligerent Behavior foreign allies
begin to distance themselves from the US
damaging National Security number one is
this already happening number one number
one thank you Pentagon but by the way
are you trying to tell us something this
is literally the report where someone
keeps giving you gum they're like do you
want gum you sure you don't want any gum
no no no it's not your breath you just
look good chewing gum you want a
mint uh the fact that they would leak a
report like this that they would write a
report like this where they go hey our
biggest threat is old people that will
not give up their jobs old Boomers who
will not give up power so much so that
these conversations have been had this
is not new do you know for this to be
written you know for a fact somebody has
suggested putting a chip in Biden's head
that would allow him to walk out on the
debates throwing footballs Shadow Boxing
like they want that guy to have some
level of cognitive ability that
convinces people he can run the country
so the fact that they're coming out and
going this is actually a threat this is
actually something it's a genuine threat
that these people are so power hungry
that they don't want to leave they don't
want to leave they will not leave they
will not retire they will not go sit by
a beach they're not built to do that
they are built only to destroy and if
they can't they get very upset so much
so that they will put chips in their
head that will allow them to walk
around appearing to be normal after
years of cognitive CLI so in this
scenario Biden just walks out on the
stage with the pep of Gavin Nome or a
younger guy and you just have to go ah
good for him good for him good for him
wow he really turned it
around they're basically almost leaking
maybe what'll happen in the debate if he
walks out in the debate and he looks
like a
40-year-old like in the way that he's
talking and speaking know that it's the
I though is going to be a cocktail of
drugs I thought it was going to be fizer
I thought it was going to be madna or
whatever uh you know uh whatever
pharmaceutical company MC I thought they
were going to whip up a concoction but
the pentagon's going no it's going to be
a chip in their head that's the way that
this is going to work
so you're also going to have to contend
with this as you could all you're going
to have to force old p and this is going
to be unfortunate
now here's why
disconnects to the immigrants the
Boomers were supposed to retire and
immigrants were supposed to come in and
work in the health care field because
nobody wants to deal with dying Boomers
in in uh hospitals it's a horrible idea
no person in this country that has any
option wants to wipe the ass of a boomer
who's dying and complaining in a like a
state run facility which is where many
of them will be many of these boomers
are going to be exped Hing and they're
going to hang on to the dear life you
know they're going to be nasty you know
how there's going to be uh you know how
there's you elder abuse in these nursing
homes this is going to be the first time
it's Justified where you don't feel bad
for them at all you know what I mean
where just some some Spanish chicks
going to just punch This Woman This old
lady in a face and you're gonna you're
gonna be like well you know this was you
know there the the Boomer going to be in
these hospitals right calling these
people the
nword [__] themselves complaining
about the food uh complaining about
their children because their children
are going to put them there and we're
this is why immigrants were kind of
coming in because we were going to let
these poor people that are getting
chased around Ecuador right now by
Gorilla gangs we were going to bring
them into our country and say wipe that
Boomer's ass uh because none of us want
to
that's that's kind of what's going to
happen but these Boomers by the way are
like they're refusing to even they won't
even it's not even happen happening yet
now eventually it will because they'll
physically decline there's an
inevitability to that but that's what I
mean about immigration it's like it
can't just be it's not all or nothing
it's not like we need no immigrants or
we need all of the immigrants all the
time every hour on the hour here they
come and it's it's it's it's it's a it's
a case by case you got to look at the
world and go so but but we do we will
need some we have a lot we have a lot
right now we'll probably need some as
the Boomers in Mass start to physically
Decline and cuz the
Boomers you know are are how many of
them are there by the way this is
something that we should talk in actual
statistics here because I'm proposing
Solutions a lot of people listen to the
show very
influential there are 76 million Boomers
this is the way you have to sell
immigration to the country because I do
believe we need some of it we don't need
all of it and we don't not in the way we
have it but now you have to sell
immigration to the country like this you
go there's 80 million people okay about
76 million baby boomers living in the US
today they're all in their 60s but
primarily
70s and they're all maybe it's early 70s
a lot of them they're all beginning to
slow down they're getting
crazier they're becoming threats to the
public Public Health the ones that have
positions of power will not relinquish
them we will need immigrants to you know
ideally put these people in these little
prisons we're going to have to drag them
out of their homes and put them in these
little prisons that's really the only
way these we're going to call them
Health Facilities but make no mistake
they will be prisons and we're going to
have to commit in Mass tens of millions
of Boomers against their will into
prisons run by illegal immigrant
Hondurans that are going to have to
because they have all the jails in the
Latin America they know how to do it
they know how to run a prison these
people they do who knows how to run a
prison the Dutch the Latin Americans
know how to run a prison they know
there's a certain amount of corruption
that's needed and whatever but boomers
are going to have to be committed
against their will their property is
going to have to be confiscated okay uh
it's going to have to be kind of
chairman Ma it's no it's not yours
anymore Mom it's not yours we're going
to have to take houses from them by
force confiscate their property
confiscate their land commit them
against their will in a
statun health
facilities health facilities and the
reason this must be done is because if
it is not done these people will figure
out a Pinky and the Brain style way to
destroy our world they will crash the
stock market they will do some I don't
know what it is I I haven't had that
Vision yet I haven't taken the iasa
needed to have the vision maybe someone
will show me in a dream how the Boomers
will do but they will do it and this is
why every article now is like the
Pentagon the Pentagon going watch them
watch them we don't know what to do
I've been talking to them and I've been
seeing
um I've been seeing their attitudes you
know young people or middle-aged people
are kind of nervous and worried about
this upcoming year because they think
you know that things could unspool in a
way that wouldn't be but boomers are
kind of Giddy and happy they're at
they're enjoying this they like it they
like they were responded to Nikki H
Nikki Haley came out and goes hey I'm
like a boring Republican I'm kind of
what you guys grew up with and they were
like [__] you [__] you get out of here
you stupid [__] we don't want
you and in the same way the Boomers on
the other side because Boomers they're
apolitical there are boomers that love
Biden and hate Trump and there are
boomers that hate Biden and love Trump
it's not a political movement and
they're the same people and they don't
even care politics is the only sport
they have left it's the only one that
they uh care
about um there's too many minorities in
the other sports for them to get really
uh invested in it but the the the thing
is it's not a political movement they
don't care the ones on the left and the
ones on the right only want to win at
the expense of all else including they
would they would gladly stand by for the
destruction of the country to be
right they just want to be right they
would gladly stand by for you know there
are these great
like episodes things that
where I can't even recall what they are
but I've seen this type of plot device
used in many uh artistic
depictions uh of things where someone's
offered immortality for something and
they go no I don't want immortality
I don't want it I don't like the cost
you go you can live forever but it's
like that the fouyan bargain that thing
of like hey you can live forever you
know being a
vampire you could live forever you can't
go out in the
day you can only go out at
night and you got to suck uh people's
blood but here's the good news you'll be
around
forever that's kind of what we're
dealing with here we're dealing with
with a group of people that doesn't
care what happens to anyone else they
don't care what happens to anyone that
is why the Pentagon the Pentagon is is
regarding the selfishness of that
generation as a national security threat
as an actual national security
threat it's it's really
amazing and unfortunate Taco Bell prices
and this is another thing we should
remind people that things steadily get
more expensive that's why it's best to
own assets this is not a financial
advice show
now $20 a Taco Bell buys you a lot less
now than it would have when we all fell
in love with Taco Bell in the early
alts now play this lovely woman this
woman here is is reminding us of what we
had sometimes in America you must look
at what you had and lost and this woman
has the courage to remind us because in
the great golden age of fast food in the
late 90s and the early 2000s when we
were comforting ourselves in the grilled
stuff burrito while watching our fellow
citizens jump out of Windows on
[Laughter]
911 we were eating the
Wendy's monter r chicken sandwich bacon
in the ranch dressing in a gold wrapper
with monter Jack cheese eating it as we
watch cigarette smoking girl put uh
young mostly innocent uh Arabs on
leashes and walked them around Abu grabe
and we were uncomfortable with that but
we only took comfort in the Monterey
ranch chicken sandwich or the um honey
barbecue chicken wing from KFC that they
don't really even have anymore the Great
great bone honey barbecue chicken wing
we would eat that okay while we would
watch uh many of our fellow citizens
lose their
houses so this woman is reminding us
of time's gone by I just found a taco
barell receipt from
2012 two beafy 5 L burritos total
259 can you even get anything from Taco
Bell for 259 anymore like one
item where we go
wrong what's great about
this we will never get mad at the poison
in the food never I'm never mad at it
Bill Burr is some people are I'm never
met I should be but we never seem to get
an like no one cared remember the whole
Monsanto thing no one cared it was like
a couple of riched white [__] from
the Malibu it was like Robert
RFK and his crew were mad about it and
like you know I respect him but it never
galvanized any public support like no
one cared no there was a couple of
people in the Pacific Palisades that
were like this is sick but nobody cared
the rage is always at the price of the
poison it's never at the actual the rage
is always at how much it costs to die
people just want to Die For Less that's
really what it comes down to Just Kill
Me For Less I know you're killing me I'm
pulling in to a building that is
illuminated with light it's 1 o'clock in
the
morning I should be in bed hours ago but
I'm here and there's other people here
and we're on a line to be handed
burritos through a window so we can eat
them we know you're killing
us just do it for
Less how much do you have to pay in this
country to get cancer how much that's a
real question how much do you have to
pay in this country to destroy the
bacteria in your gut biome can't you
just pay because she said it she goes
where do we go wrong you used to be able
to get two beefy five layer burritos get
up the nutritional information on the
beefy five layer burrito we used to be
able to get two of them for $259 259 you
you were able to eat not only one but
two beefy five layer burritos
okay it has 18 grams of fat it's a 500
calorie item so two of them would be a
th000
calories 70 carbs about 60 net carbs 18
grams of fat 18 grams of protein 490
calories now with this obscure yours of
course is that none of the food in it is
real this makes it sound a bit better
than it is but it's actually plastic and
Taco Bells like grade D meat and it's
lovely it tastes great but it's D meat
meaning I don't think it's from any
specific animal really it's just
whatever they got it's whatever they got
it's up in Sinclair the jungle old mck
raking meat factory just whatever they
got you know if they came out with that
book today no one would
care
MH they're lying Taco Bellos we use 100%
SDA premium beef that's a lie that's a
lie 12%
seasonings okay but here's the deal
Upton Sinclair wrote a book about how
disgusting the meat packing industry was
uh in the early days of this country um
and it was it was like a he was a
muckraking
journalist and I believe that that was
the title right the jungle yeah and it
was about I mean it was like swe Todd in
there people's fingers were in the meat
people's earlobes it was disgusting I
mean so the jungle led to us food safety
reforms because as you look at this
photo these are like Christmas elves
these little kids and they're just
making sausages out of whatever they
found if there was a dog on the floor he
went into the sausage everything was in
a sausage in the early days of this
country and up Sinclair wrote that book
now if you wrote a book right now do you
know how many books there are about the
poison that we're eating all the time
walls there are walls of books about how
bad it all is but we all lack like no
one care I and I don't care so I'm not
judging anyone for not caring I'm just
saying no one cares no people kind of
laugh it off people go yeah no one cares
and it's funny it's just it's just
that's kind of a brilliant point point
the woman just goes used to be able to
get two of these used to be able to eat
a thousand calories in five minutes mhm
for under $3 under $3 half the day's
calories of garbage poison food for $3
you know be it's it is a good
deal in America you accept that every
corporations kind of trying to kill you
you accept
that the corporations are dumping poison
in the rivers and the lakes where you
live they're putting bad [__] into the
atmosphere they're poisoning the water
they're poisoning the food uh they're
coming up with uh different ways uh for
you to die doing different things and
you kind of accept that you kind of just
want a good deal you kind of want a good
deal we accept the moral compromises you
have to make to be rich and we're all
prepared to make them that's why we
accept it we're all prepared to kind of
make the moral compromises you need to
make to be right nobody in this country
is not wealthy because they're too good
of a person that's that is not happening
here there are other countries where
that probably plays into it that is a
factor nobody in America is not rich
because they're too moral they might be
too dumb they might have had a bad break
there might be a tiny small infinim
percentage of the
population that is not doing well
because they are too moral or they uh
are are are too good and they've you
know they chose to care for their sick
mother whatever but not none of the
Boomers I'll say none of them um we're
all kind of prep you we kind of prepare
you early on to get ready to make some
moral compromises in the world that's
what we prepare you to do early on in
this country that's what that's part of
the ethos of this country that's what we
do the whole thing's kind of that so
yeah we know you're poisoning us and
because we would poison us too we would
do it like we get it we get it if I had
that I'd poison P like and that's how
you're
raised in this C you're raised in this
country to believe that if you work hard
and you do the right thing eventually
you're going to be able to do the wrong
thing that's the that's really what it
comes out to if you work hard enough you
can kill people you can kill people too
and you could live in a gated community
in Gilbert Arizona you can fight you can
work hard but there's just
no there's no rage at the at the
poisoning of our food or our water
assist there's just not a lot of it
there's there's not a lot of rate it's
it's a hard thing to get upset about
because it's you know that's the other
thing it's like you know what people
really get upset about people really get
upset about like like uh the money they
pay to change their
flight they hate that they go it's
$500 and then they'll tell you they'll
brag to you that they actually were able
to do his flight change for
$75 they beat Delta the least
interesting people in the world are
constantly talking about how they beat
an airline and they were they only had
to pay
$75 the least interesting most banal
people on Earth are only concerned with
telling you how they beat a corporation
out of a little bit of money and they
feel like a winner they feel like a
winner so that's really what it come
it's just an economic analysis across
the board of most things it's not
quality of life it's not longevity or
whatever it's like I beat the I beat
them I beat them there was an extra
mozzarella stick in this I
won I won I had a friend who was telling
I two people sing in my house one of my
friends was telling the other this guy
didn't even know him my friend's little
brother say me this guy's going uh let
me tell you about the flight
change my friends little brother's going
what
he's going well they want the new flight
would be $500 but I can change it for 75
and he's showing him the app and
everything my friend's little brother's
like who is this weirdo get away from
me but that's what rils people up not
knowing they've been poisoned they don't
care they don't care I will I don't
care I if I was sitting at a restaurant
and they go and somebody comes up to me
go you know all this is poison right I
go yeah yeah yeah what are you going to
do start a
farm are you going to start
farming what are you going to
do build a water treatment facility what
is the option you know especially if
you're broke what would the option be
how do you fight back against the PO I
mean you could not eat or you could not
eat crap which is good you could do your
best and you could do a lot better
obviously the extreme examples are like
you could cut out the fast
food but it's so godamn they're so good
at marketing that
[__] they're so good at marketing that
[__] my godson came to my house now he's
Chinese he can't be polluted with this
the Chinese run on a different thing
than the
others they do there there's an
efficiency see there it's it's different
Chinese people cannot be made in into
fatty Bo Bates it's not good it won't
work everyone has a different thing
okay my godson comes to my house in the
Hamptons The Hamptons has fresh
vegetables fresh bread fresh butter
fresh eggs they have Farms on the North
Fork of Long Island the mother the
mother Postmates him chicken
nuggets he's 2 years old he's eating
post-m chicken
nuggets in New Hampton I go let's make
him a grilled cheese or something but
he's already addicted to the PO he's
postm he goes nuggets and I'm like no no
no no no he's
Chinese this won't work this this won't
do he needs bok choy
broth truly you know that's what he need
he's to be given broth bone broth bok
choy different
vegetables you know and and yes he like
yes every now and then he can step into
the American genre of
food but there's something I'm sorry I'm
gonna get a lot of flak for saying this
and a lot of people are going to be
upset about
me I know that we drop bombs on Japan I
know that we've raped and pillaged the
third world I know that the CIA has
backed coups all over the world I know
that we've done all this bad stuff to me
the most offensive thing we've ever done
is when I see a really fat
asian when I see a really fat asian I go
what have we done have we no decency
will we never stop when I see a real
supremely fat I don't mean chubby we all
like a chubby Asian a chubby Asian is
great but an American style fat asian
where you're worried about Mobility
when I see an Asian of that girth I am I
am I shudder with the horror of what
we've done no I do I shudder because I
go it's crazy the crazy billionaire
daughter at the LA Times is losing her
mind and destroying the paper which is
what the the children of billionaires
tend to
do a lot of people that have successful
parents never get out of the shadow of
that this is true and they're unable to
do it LA Times billionaire owner and his
family ignited tuger War over paper's
Future
Okay so the billionaire owner is Patrick
Sun xang Patrick Sun Shang his daughter
and the outlets leadership are being
drawn
uh as top editor Kevin mirinda calls it
quits fault lines between the
billionaire
owner Patrick Sun Shang his daughter and
the outlets leadership is being are
being drawn over how to run the business
people are upset the LA Times took out a
thing defending the Hamas right saying
what that they weren't really raping
people what did they say there oh yeah
they know they basically were saying
that it it wasn't as bad as as it
was I'll tell you right now A it's very
interesting
because who's worse a woke Asian or a
fat asian that's an interesting question
or a fat woke Asian a fat woke Asian
might be the worst archetype of person
on the planet a very fat WC asan they
are because you can't because number one
you have reverence for them you have
reverence for a fat woke Asian when a
fat when I watch any fat woke asan woke
whites I go
out I'll listen to some woke blacks I
will but when a fat woke Asian comes out
there's something spiritual about them
and I listen and and it never makes much
sense but you still listen but it's
terrifying is this is his daughter fat
no she's she's normal get a photo of her
here car let's get a photo of this woman
I want to know who I hate and
why oh my God she seems annoying she got
the Palestinian flag in her Twitter
handle listen she's allowed to support
Palestine people I don't
care the Asians are trying to pretend
that they that that like they've never
colonized anything that's not true
that's not true it's like it's this
thing like we're turning Native
Americans into [__] it's like they
were warriors they used to kill each
other all the time and that's why
they're cool sorry they used to kill
each other all the time and that's why
they're cool you can't make them into
[__] you can't they were warriors
proud Warriors you cannot make them into
[__]
okay um I I will not listen to her
because I want her to be fatter and I
want her to have a cherubic thing I
don't I can't listen to her there's I
it's there is no novelty in a thin woke
Asian give me a fat woke Asian and I
will listen far-left
fat asian and I'm in I'm
in
always you make them trans I'll watch it
for two
hours because it's like a Pokemon it's a
fun Pokemon come to life it's a fun
Pokemon that's kind of why people watch
me they're like oh he's like some
Pokemon villain these fat wcas are
watching me and they're going you give
me a fat white
supremacist with sunglasses I'll watch
that we're all curious everybody's
curious about everybody else
here I have had so many friends that
have been telling me about Mor in Morgan
and that they have had great experiences
with them they're the largest personal
injury law firm in America and my
friends have been getting in car
accidents and falling down the stairs
and you know one of them went up the
wrong way in an escalator but it was
somehow it was the mall's fault but
here's the point the point is that a lot
of my friends are kutes and clumsy
because but it's not really their fault
it's they're put in dangerous situations
all the time right and you know my
friend recently just literally became
paralyzed from an incident in a frozen
yogurt shop and what I've realized here
is that number one you're going to get
in car accident it's going to happen
right I mean it's just bumper cars out
there it's so crazy and with over $20
billion recovered from over 500,000
clients Morgan and Morgan has a proven
track record are fighting to get you
full and fair compensation submitting an
injury claim with Morgan and Morgan is
so easy so if you're out there and
things are happening to you you're in a
car somebody whacks you in your car you
go submit an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan life is hard submitting a
claim with Morgan and Morgan is easy
calculus is hard submitting an injury
looking your father in his eyes is hard
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is easy if you're ever
injured you could check out Morgan and
Morgan their fee is free unless they win
hello for more information go to
forthepeople.com
Tim forthepeople.com Tim or dial pound
law pound 529 from your cell phone
that's fthe people.com Tim or pound a
pound 529 from your sale this is a paid
advertisement I'm telling you right now
I love Stitch fix this year you can make
great style effortlessly easy with
Stitch fix Stitch fix stylist just get
you they do all the work giving you the
time to focus on your resolutions and
everything else on your plate finding
new clothes is hard GH I'm leaving
scrolling through countless websites and
spending hours wandering through crowded
stores in 2023 instead I'm transforming
my shopping experience with the stylist
at Stitch Fix You Go out there and you
see people dressed well you go how do
they do it and you look at yourself and
you look like kind of a bum like a slob
and you know some people can pull that
off but you might want to step it up
step it up you want to have what the the
kids call a glow up Stitch fix is an
easy way to get clothes that fit you
without having to endlessly browse
through options or break the bank think
of them as your style partner your
stylist will learn about your taste and
collaborate with the you on looks you
love here's the thing you think of like
oh I can't have a stylist I'm not
Jennifer Lopez that's what I said to my
friend my friend said to me once we were
having lunch he goes why do you look
like a slob all the time I go well I'm
not Jennifer Lopez I can't afford a
stylist and he goes have you heard of
Stitch fix I said what he goes Stitch
fix they have over a thousand Brands and
styles and they do the work of choosing
the best options for you they'll even
show you how to wear head to toe outfits
you could just keep getting dressed and
go and if you don't love something just
send it back I mean that's amazing this
idea that you have to be a famous
celebrity to have a stylist is not true
it you know experts experts in your look
no matter what your body type is you
know experts are coming in and they're
like hey let's transform you this is a
great new way to to to interface with
the world thanks Stitch fix they just
get me and they'll get you too try today
at stitchfix.com and you'll get 25% off
when you keep everything in your fix
that's
stitchfix.com
it is a great way to do this truly
it's the easiest thing out there stores
terrible terrible leaving house no no
good wandering through malls stores
you're staying there it's hours of your
day it's traffic it's gross not good
online you don't know what's going to
work what's going to fit you how it'll
all come together how it'll look you use
this service Stitch fix a brilliant
service you're actually working with
genuine designers and stylists who can
make you look better the clothes are
shipped directly to your door shipping
returns and exchanges are always free so
basically this is door dash for your
body this is Postmates for your clothes
it's Uber for it's all of the
convenience of those services for your
body for clothing it's really a
revolutionary thing and they're offering
you 25% off when you keep everything in
your fix
so try today stitchfix.com timy you'll
get 25% off when you keep everything in
your fix that's stitchfix.com Tim Dyan
comedy.com uh we're on the road for the
next three months and then I'm off for
the rest of the year where can you see
me well you miss San Antonio and you
miss Dallas when does this come out
tomorrow Saturday well Dallas is gone
anyway Atlanta Georgia Saturday you can
come see me the Tabernacle a few seats
left St Louis Indianapolis West nyak New
York we're in a club we're having fun
it's about an hour out of the city if
you miss me at Carie Hall if you want to
come again because whatever uh if you
are live in that area Boston the fourth
show at the Wilbur has been added we've
sold that three or very near it very
near it you can get one of those other
three there are a few tickets left um
and then the four show has been added
Foxwoods then we're Chicago we're going
to do a club there Dania Beach Tula
Indio
Phoenix Atlantic
City Tim Dillan comedy.com for all of
your tickets and your needs subscribe uh
to the channel on YouTube we appreciate
it we are
excited um and we're having a lot of fun
and we are hopefully bringing things to
light that you haven't you know and I
mean again I'm not going to go into the
Gilbert thing all the time but to to
just Pat myself on the back a little bit
here
what I do I
mean I'm I'm solving
murders in my spare time no really truly
people think I'm just like going out
here and running my mouth but the
reality is I'm
literally solving
murders I'm
literally
making the streets safer for the people
of Arizona a place I don't even
particularly love and I'm out there
making things better and Pat on my hear
that that's a pat on my back that I'm
not getting from the governor of that
state Katie Hobbs maybe she's in a hair
salon that's where she should be but no
one is called if I were her I would call
me I should get a phone call Mr dyllan
please hold for the governor of Arizona
thank you
thank you for all that you do for the
people of the litter box of my state
thank you for the hot desert hell dirt
with the from the hell dirt we thank you
Mr Dylan for everything you're
doing because they all these people are
getting popped now these uh kids and
their families and drugs they get popped
the family gets popped for drugs you've
known for two months they already raided
the house call me and tell me I'll tell
you how to get away with this I'm for
sale if these [__] are that
Rich call me I'm for sale I'll help you
get away with it call I am the most
underutilized resource in the
media I Am for sale I'm going the way of
good now because that's my default no
one's offered nobody sweetened the pot
nobody sweeten the pot you give me a
orange theory Jim you you franchise me
in a c couple of things let's talk I'll
have you all around me rehabilitate your
asses I will have your family on my show
and we will talk only about
Fitness we'll rehabilitate the whole
family but it doesn't come cheap doesn't
come cheap
okay so if you're interested back
Channel and I will and I will have all
of you on and we will talk about how
great you all are and how you've been
you've been uh waylay by these lies
about you but get the drugs out of the
house you [__]
idiots are you really you guys really
are goons down there I grew up around
great
criminals really smart conscientious
criminals my mother rented rooms to drug
dealers for years which made number one
being a teenager convenient vent but
they would live in my house and and my
house got raided a few times like cops
would come and PE you know what people
would do they would remove the
[Music]
drugs I mean isn't that [__]
hard
God
anyway the boomers are going to be more
dangerous than the
goons watch